[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
sa cuisine
je me suis aperçu que c'était bien plus
difficile qu'ils avaient une équipe de
25 usines et autour pour nous pour nos
fournisseurs pour nos équipes c'était
essentiel d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le groupe d'avants
il était formidable et qu'on a envie de
le retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ça m'a rendu
plus intolérant alors parfois elle cela
devrait vous proposer justement délirer
autour d'un dessert que j'ai appelé la
pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde à man
[Musique]
pourquoi une banque disparaîtrait pas
pourquoi pas bien sûr la banque ne gagne
pas d'argent sur son métier traditionnel
mais gagne de l'argent uniquement sur
des opérations marche deux mois de non
consommation mondiale et les plus gros
groupe s'arrête et 10 on n'a pas de
trésorerie
c'est un modèle assez extraordinaire à
la banque c'est à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant c'était privatisation des
gains et mutualisation des pertes donc
en fait c'est fâcheux gagne pile tu
perds ont créé une économie qui n'a zéro
valeur
statistiquement vous aurez une banque en
europe une banque majeur en europe qui
sautera
[Musique]
m
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi
l essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters à voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 14 juillet 2020
le chef de l'état a accepté de se
soumettre pour la première fois depuis
son élection à la traditionnelle
interview du 14 juillet crise sanitaire
plan de relance économique nouveau
gouvernement écologie ou encore réforme
des retraites
il est revenu sur les dossiers chauds du
moment mais cette prise de parole et les
célébrations du jour n'ont pas suffi à
calmer l'ardeur de la rue à des
soignants et des gilets jaunes ont
manifesté tout au long de la journée
telles que heurts avec les forces de
l'ordre ont eu lieu dans la capitale aux
états unis à la californie se re
consignes le gouverneur a ordonné la
fermeture des bars salles de restaurants
lieux de culte ou encore cinéma à ces
dernières restrictions concernent 32
millions d'habitants est la californie
avait été le premier état à imposer un
confinement général en mars dernier mais
le nombre de cas explose depuis
plusieurs semaines nouveau conflit entre
les états unis et la chine pour le chef
de la diplomatie américaine les
revendications territoriales de pékin en
mer de chine méridionale sont illégales
pékin dénonce elle une tentative
américaine pour saper la stabilité
régionale
à la fête nationale dans le sillage de
la crise sanitaire a donc été marquée
par une cérémonie inédite en hommage aux
soignants mais aussi par l'interview
télévisée d'emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état a finalement accepté de se plier
à l'exercice du traditionnel entretien
du 14 juillet à crise sanitaire
économique et social il a fait le tour
de l'actualité
à moins de deux ans de la fin de son
mandat a parmi les annonces elles
attendues sur les masques son port dans
les lieux publics clos devra être
obligatoire dès le 1er août
mais également l'annoncé d'un plan de
relance massif il devrait atteindre
selon lui au moins 100 milliards d'euros
en plus de l'argent des familles et pour
revenir sur l'interview d'emmanuel
macron nous sommes avec stéphane rozès
président de cap conseil analyse et
perspective politologue enseignant à
sciences po et hec avec nous également
florian philippot président des
patriotes bonsoir messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
une réaction plus générale peut-être
pour commencer le président a dit ne pas
changer le cap mais prendre je cite un
nouveau chemin vous l'avez trouvé clerc
pour expliquer ce nouveau chemin
stéphane rozès il a pu être décevant
dans la mesure où cette interview était
très attendue au fond après une période
social marqué par les mouvements des
chiffres des choux et des retraites
évidemment une crise sanitaire de très
grande ampleur inusuelles et en amont
d'un choc économique et social
le président nous avait annoncé un
nouveau chemin dont on a peine à voir au
fond la cohérence ou la nouveauté dans
la mesure où le président a fait surtout
un mea culpa de former pas véritablement
de fond il n'a pas expliqué les raisons
profondes de la dépression française
mais nous ré activer du délitement de
son lien avec la nation par contre il a
annoncé évidemment des mesures mais le
pays est sans doute restée sur sa faim
il y avait là une occasion
exceptionnelle
le moment exceptionnel que nous
connaissons et je dirais que
l'intervention qui a duré monde en 1h20
a manqué sans doute de vision de souffle
eu de diagnostic profond de sorte que le
président semble par différentes mesures
essayer de colmater une situation
difficile sans que véritablement le pays
a une perspective de moyen et de long
terme puisque c'est ça qui avait été
annoncé par le président de macron
florian philippot un manque de vision
malgré l'annoncé d'un nouveau chemin
également selon vous c'est à dire qu'il
a annoncé un nouveau chemin mais je n'ai
pas très bien compris en quoi le nouveau
chemin était différent de l'ancien
chemin
bon si ce n'est que l'on traversera le
nouveau chemin avec un mass pistilli
bien suivi mais je vois pas la
différence au delà de ça moi ce qui m'a
frappé dans cette interview c'est que
d'abord le la glorification de son
supposé bilan presque vide
si elle qu'on a eu le sentiment à
l'écouté aujourd'hui qu' il n'y a pas eu
de chance il ya eu le corps et les
russes mais qu'avant tout était en
merveilleuse voix se dire qu'il est en
train de résoudre le problème du chômage
il était en train de régler comme il le
fallait le premier déficit point de la
pauvreté de ça je crois que les français
ont un tout petit peu de mémoire se
souviennent du monde la france d'avant
confinement ce n'était pas tout à fait
comme ça que ça se passe ça se passait
les résultats n'étaient pas là la
politique était très injuste il y avait
déjà beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
désordres sociaux de manifestations et
mobilisations enfin je crois que chacun
s'en souvient la soul est on est on est
frappé par une crise qui ont un
historique on va avoir une réception de
10 11 12 % d'après les plus grandes
instances économiques et on se dit mais
qu'est ce qui va changer on était rien
ne va changer et à mon avis pour une
raison simple c'est qu'on ne reste en
même temps on reste dans l'union
européenne on reste dans le rouge donc
on va appliquer les mêmes politiques et
est donc macro et bien impuissant à dire
ce qu'il peut changer parce qu'en fait
ils ne peuvent rien changer et civils et
n'a pas les grands instruments de
souveraineté pour changer la politique
de la france alors il joue sur deux
trois détails de 3 mesurettes mais
fondamentalement il va mener demain la
même politique qu'il a menée hier parce
que
la france n'a plus les grands
instruments de souveraineté du fait
qu'elle appartient à l'union européenne
et à l'euro pour changer sa politique
et c'est bien là de l'un des drames de
notre pays va bien falloir un jour qu'on
affronte ce problème là le bihan tête
alors le chef de l'état qui a commencé
par s'exprimer sur ce qu'ils percevaient
des tas de l'esprit du pays ont regardé
vous réagissez ensuite notre pays au
fonds a peur et à une crise de confiance
confiance à l'égard de lui même
regardez la période récente que nous
venons de franchir si nous nous
écoutions nous mêmes on faisait moins
bien que les voisins nous étions les
pires quand on commence à regarder le
bilan non on est loin d'être les pires
mais nous avons en quelque sorte un
doute permanent sur nous mêmes en tant
que pays alors est ce que vous le
rejoignez si on m'écoutait nous serions
les pires nous traversons une crise de
confiance des fans rozès je suis
d'accord avec le diagnostic nous sommes
les plus pessimistes au monde avec un ou
deux pays en situation économique et
sociale très difficile est selon moi la
dépression française n'a pas tant une
raison économique et social car notre
modèle social quoique très dégradée
demeure enviable et enviés par rapport à
d'autres pays y compris des pays voisins
mais à des raisons culturelles
c'est à dire que la france notre nation
pour se déployer a besoin de ce proche
jeter dans l'espace et le temps or notre
état néolibéral est enclavée au
contraire dans des politiques
européennes procédurale de nature
économique et c'est cette contradiction
qui fait des pressions or emmanuel mâcon
si pendant un an il a pu réformer le
pays alors même que des français
estimaient ces réforme injuste
économiquement et socialement c'est que
comme il l'avait dit c'était fait ou non
de la restauration de la souveraineté de
la nation il avait dit devant le congrès
le premier mandat que m'ont confié les
français c'est la restauration de la
souveraineté de la nation aura un an
après son élection
après que la chancelière merkel des
privés d'une deuxième étape de son
mouvement
il appellera tête à queue silencieux et
là c'est là j'ai créé des files à jour
c'est à dire qu'il a raison sur le
constat mais il ne va pas au fond de
l'explication qui est que justement la
politique qui a été menée
facialement ou en tout cas sa
justification
un an après son élection ça a été au
fond pour les français une reprise à peu
près de des politiques de ses
prédécesseurs et donc c'est là où il ne
va pas au bout du chemin si je peux me
permettre c'est à dire que le constat
est juste mais il ne dit pas les
éléments de nature politique dont il est
au premier chef le responsable le
tracteur pour expliquer justement cette
dépression et cette contradiction entre
une situation économique et sociale
encore par rapport à nos voisins ont via
blé envié et une dépression du pays et
un lien d'équité entre le président et
la nation florian philippot comment
fait-on alors pour surmonter cette crise
de confiance diagnostiqué par le
président ahmad al macro ya une question
à se poser comment voulez vous que le
peuple français est pleinement confiance
dans son propre pays qu'en depuis 40 ans
je crois que ça a commencé avec le
valéry giscard d'estaing s'est pas tout
à fait raison les élites à la tête du
pays ne passent leur vie à expliquer aux
français que leur pays de façon n'a pas
d'avenir qu'ils ne représentent pas
grand chose des giscard qui disait on
est que 1% de la population mondiale
on est depuis sans ce moyenne et puis
ensuite mitterrand a ajouté que certes
la france était notre patrie mais que
notre avenir c'est l europe
sous-entendu la france n'est même pas
notre avenir et puis et puis on a ajouté
toutes les politiques et traités etc
jusqu'à macron et les maths moi-même en
permanence de souveraineté européenne
sous-entendu il peut même pu y avoir de
souveraineté nationale réelle
comment voyez vous que le peuple
français les confiance quand il voit à
ses chefs ne pas avoir confiance
justement dans le pays dans sa capacité
à être un pays libre pays souverain et
avoir un avenir propre
je crois que le malaise il réside là et
vas-y tu là le jour où on aura des chefs
des présidents des premiers nice des
chefs de gouvernements qui auront
vraiment l'amour et la confiance de la
france
la confiance en la france alors ils
auront la confiance du peuple français
mais aujourd'hui ça n'est pas possible
de croire dans un pays si les chefs de
ce pays eux-mêmes ne croient pas dans le
pays et c'est ce qui est bien c'est ce
qu'il ne cesse de transférer notre
souveraineté à des instances
supranationales
c'est donc l'élu pense que la france ne
peut pas le faire elle même et je crois
que la contradiction le malaise il vient
profondément delà du sens une nation
très politique
une nation qui s'est battu toute sa vie
c'est mam naissance de la france pour sa
liberté pour son indépendance
à partir du moment où on lui explique
que ça n'est plus possible et va
supprimer une nouvelle dépression on est
en dépression nationale et ça ne peut
pas s'arranger
tant qu'on ne change pas de logiciel et
macro nous avions annoncé aujourd'hui
une rupture il va annoncer la continuité
malheureusement en tout l'état il a pris
ses responsabilités on aurait pu
entendre à son son mea culpa je n'ai pas
réussi à réconcilier les français j'ai
donné le sentiment qu'au fond je réformé
pour eux où malgré eux et qui n'était
pas juste je n'ai pas assez montré un
chemin de justice
il a aussi pris acte de la détestation
contre lui en déplorant la haine
notamment celles qu'il perçoit dans les
manifestations comment est ce que vous
avez reçues ces déclarations ce n'est
pas de rozès je les ai reçus comme juste
objectivement mais au fond emmanuel
mâcon semble dire au pays que il
faudrait en passer par là qu'il
prendrait sur ses épaules ce poids qu'il
faudrait payer comme si l'alternative du
pays était pour survivre d'en passer par
là
or il y à un imaginaire français qui
date de quelques siècles
et lorsque la crise pandémique arrive
puisque une pandémie posséda question de
la vie et de la mort individuelles et
collectives
kosa question de qu'est-ce qu'une
communauté nationale
on a vu le président revenir à des
fondamentaux de notre imaginaire il a
utilisé le terme de souveraineté
nationale de modèle social
puis il a parlé de souveraineté
nationale souveraineté européenne puis
dans la dernière déclaration
d'indépendance nationale et maintenant
on entend plus effectivement de
perspectives de nature politique
or le propos qui est le mien n'est pas
celui d'un politologue s'intéressant ou
dimension anthropologique de la nation
c'est que il faut bien comprendre que
nous allons subir une subissons une
crise de l'offre et de la demande et que
la dépression morales et politiques
empêchent les consommateurs et ménages
de limiter des parm de précaution en
consommant et empêche les chefs
d'entreprise à investir en un mot le
défaut de vision du président en fait
n'est pas du tout une incitation pour
les français acteur et agents
économiques de prendre à paris sur
l'avenir car justement le président se
contentent d'acter ce qu'ils disent
fonctionnerait sans dire l'essentiel
pour les français c'est là où il
amènerait la france comme si la france
devait 116 choisir entre la survie et au
fond le renoncement à peser or c'est là
où le président mâcon est très étonnant
c'est que contrairement à ses
prédécesseurs il met beaucoup plus des
mots sur le constat de la dépression
mais en fait derrière ils n'en tirent
pas de leçons comme signes sont
contentes est de constater que pour
l'heure comme n'aurait pas d'opposants
crédibles et réalistes
il pourrait continuer ainsi avec le
puis c'est selon moi très dangereux les
gilets jaunes ont montré c'était selon
moi il n'y jacquerie de sorte que le
président n'est pas un auteur politique
ce n'est qu'un acteur d'un moment et
d'une situation et je trouve qui a là
une occasion perdue
c'est à dire que lors de la
présidentielle il y avait pour lui une
occasion de construire quelque chose de
neuf
après des gilets joue il ya une deuxième
occasion de d'apt et des choses est de
construire quelque chose de neuf
et là j'ai le regret de constater qu'au
fond il ya une troisième occasion qui
n'a pas permis au président au fond de
faire une confiance exclusive dans notre
génie et dans l'intelligence les
français florian philippot à mea culpa
un simple constat c'est ce que vous
retenez vous aussi de cette prise de
parole ce matin
oui oui objectivement un mea culpa
extrêmement extrêmement léger parce que
parce qu'on voit bien que tout de suite
il précise que le problème c'était pas
tant le son que la méthode on va tout ça
je pense que ça ne trompe plus grand
monde
s'il se plaint de la détestation dont il
compte il est la victime
peut-être devrait-il se demander s'il
n'a pas en boomerang qui la sommait si
vous voulez quand on a passé sa vie il a
passé beaucoup de avec le fait moins
maintenant parce que parce que c'est ça
le plus possible et sa nature profonde
c'était quand même d'être
particulièrement méprisant avec les
français on a même oublié toutes les
séquences mais quand il parlait des
alcooliques quand il parlait des gens
qui ne sont rien quand il a parlé même
dès le début la crise et gilet jaune il
avait dit à la télévision c'était une
foule haineuse un lien sont pas des mots
très agréable sont pas des mêmes des
mots très responsable quand on est chef
d'état on ne parle pas comme ça de son
propre peuple
quoi qu'on pense d'engouement populaire
ou sociale on doit bien se garder de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu or c'est ce
qu'il a fait par choix par tempérament
même personnel et aimerait pas faute
politique
donc en contrepartie à hambourg en guise
et prient effectivement eu de haine
populaire assez assez massive et il en
est aujourd'hui
victime mais elle n'est victime en
réalité que justement de ce qu'il a semé
lui même pour le reste j'ai pas vu de
perspectives jugées peuvent une
nouveauté je me souviens des grands
discours du début de confinement où on
allait voir ce qu'on allait voir il
avait compris beaucoup de choses il
allait lui même il a lui-même se
remettre en cause et puis ils allaient
nous faire des annonces quasiment
civilisationnel à la sortie en sortie de
crise
et bien il n'en est rien resté
aujourd'hui il restera le bon petit
soldat de l'union européenne le bon
petit soldat de l'européisme et du
mondialisme et donc ils continuent de
dérouler la feuille de route que
bruxelles berlin et quelques autres léo
fx
dès lors qu'il faut florian philippot
des mesures pour la jeunesse des ans -
qui ont été annoncées bah si vous voulez
des mesures pour la jeunesse je crois
que la jeunesse attend avant tout qu'on
lui offre une espérance et un navire
dont de ce point de vue là je crois
qu'il ya une vraie un vrai manque parmi
la jeunesse de france n'a pas eu de
perspectives le tracé dans la jeunesse
elle va galérer elle va essayer de
trouver un emploi va essayer de trouver
un salaire décent à essayer de s'en
sortir de pouvoir se loger de pouvoir
vivre à peu près décemment et on n'est
pas remis si vous voulez aujourd'hui en
france parmi les premières générations
où on commence à se dire en fait on va
vivre bien moins bien que nos parents et
ça c'était quand même ça c'est une
rupture civilisationnel parce que ça
faisait longtemps qu'on avait pris
l'habitude de penser que les nouvelles
générations vivrait mieux que les
précédentes
ça n'est plus le cas il est donc temps
de se remettre profondément en question
et dreux - de remettre profondément en
question les choix politiques et
idéologiques qui ont été faits depuis
des décennies alors bien évidemment la
crise sanitaire également au coeur de
l'interview et la question du port du
masque on regarde on en parle après nous
avons des signes que ça repart quand
même un peu face à cela nous devons
prévenir et nous préparer prévenir
qu'est ce que c'est nous avons appris
pendant cette période et nous avons
appris comment se transmettait ce virus
mieux qu'au début
la meilleure prévention ce sont ce qu'on
appelle les gestes barrière contre le
virus les masques se tenir à distance et
le gel hydroalcoolique et donc il faut
continuer d'appliquer ces gestes
barrières
là dessus on voit des faiblesses donc
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on passe une étape
au gouvernement et je souhaite que dans
les prochaines semaines ont rendu
obligatoire le mas
dans tous les lieux publics clos on le
fait dans les transports ça marche très
bien mais c'est un peu erratique dans
les lieux publics clos les protocoles
par exemple restaurant fonctionne très
bien doivent être respectées mais dans
les magasins selon les magasins après ça
veut dire qu'il faut quelque chose
s'organise pas de faire du jour au
lendemain je recommande à tous nos
concitoyens qui nous écoutent de porter
le masque au maximum quand ils sont
dehors et a fortiori quand ils sont dans
un lieu clos et nous allons on va
observer la situation nous mettre en
situation de pouvoir par exemple à
partir du 1er août le rendre totalement
obligatoire alors port du masque
obligatoire à partir du 1er août donc il
a également assuré qu'en cas de seconde
vague
tout était prêt pour conclure stéphane
rozès est-ce qu'on peut le croire
oui disons que très certainement le
sommet de l'état a eu le temps de mieux
se préparer au début de la pandémie
l'objectif pour le gouvernement et le
président c'est de faire en sorte que
l'impact de la crise soit la moins forte
sur le choc économique et social qui
arrivent huit cent mille chômeurs au
moins sont attendus les premiers indices
ont plutôt réconfortant ce serait
peut-être on serait peut-être dans la
moyenne basse mais vous voyez quand même
que le choc va être terrible terrible
terrible donc le président nos
compatriotes les sauts comme disait
darmana pour éteindre un incendie mais
au fond c'est à périmètre constant ne
change on voit pas de changement de
nature de la politique on voit que pour
l'allemagne et la france
heureusement pour quelque temps on ne va
pas trop qu'on est regardant sur la
question des déficits bon on verra
d'ailleurs ce que ça veut dire sur la
réforme des retraites
en tout cas la dimension budgétaire de
la réforme des retraites mais en un mot
clairement pour l'exécutif
la priorité c'est faire en sorte que
l'impact récessif soit le moins fort
possible par rapport au risque de
reprise de la pandémie la question est
est ce que l'europe et la france
font suffisamment en termes de
politiques contracycliques rosetta stone
stéphane rozès merci on va laisser
florian philippot conclure en quelques
mots à la fois sur cette histoire de
masques et puis sur port de masque
obligatoire à partir du 1er août
et puis un mot pour conclure sur cette
interview du président de la république
si vous voulez au moment où on avait
besoin des masses ne m'avait pas et on
nous expliquait que ce sens ça ne
servait à rien et qu'on ne savait même
pas les porter bon ça c'était en février
mars aujourd'hui quand même regarder les
courbes
1 parce qu'il faut pas regarder
simplement le nombre de cas au regard du
nombre d'hospitalisations c'est ça qui
comme ça voilà la courbe en france elle
reste plate
dieu merci là on me dirait masque
obligatoire dans les lieux clos
bon je crois qu'on va avoir un peu de
mal si vous voulez comprendre je peux te
le vrai qu'on travaille sur le
traitement je préférerais que on
contrôler sérieusement nos frontières et
nos aéroports puisque ont cessé les
vocaux les journalistes qui n'ont
rapporté beaucoup des cas nouveau en
france sont des cas importés
il n'y a pas eu de contrôles aux
aéroports c'est la première chose qu'on
devrait cibler plutôt que en plein
milieu du mois en plein milieu des
vacances d'été et au début août
d'imposer forcément le masque à tout le
monde sans discernement je sais pas je
sais pas si c'est la bonne stratégie je
trouve que je trouve que c'est un peu
facile de ne pas faire l'essentiel
frontières traitement c'est lui de faire
ce qu'ils devraient lui être fait il ya
six mois et qui à l'époque n'a pas été
fait merci beaucoup à tous les deux
mercia avoue florian philippot président
est les patriotes merci stéphane rozès
président de cap politologue et
enseignant à sciences po et hec et on le
disait allez soignante était mise à
l'honneur aujourd'hui vous avez pu
suivre la cérémonie place de la concorde
à paris en direct sur rt france mais cet
hommage est loin d'être suffisant pour
certains personnels hospitaliers à six
organisations syndicales ont appelé à
une mobilisation nationale aujourd'hui
émaillé de quelques tensions elle estime
que le gouvernement méprisent leurs
métiers leurs revendications à les
précisions de notre reporter thomas
bonnin attention sur la place de la
bastille lorsque le cortège est arrivé
puisque
je vous l'avais expliqué pendant cette
marche qui a conduit la manifestation
depuis la place de la république jusqu'à
la place de la bastille les manifestants
étaient encadrés par un important
dispositif de sécurité des forces de
l'ordre très proche des manifestants ça
un petit peu échauffé les esprits
notamment en tête de cortège et puis
lorsque nous sommes arrivés ici sur la
place de la bastille le point de fin de
cette manifestation il ya des tensions
puisque certains groupes de manifestants
ont tenté de contourner le dispositif de
sécurité il ya eu des échanges de jets
de projectiles et du gaz lacrymogène a
été utilisé à de nombreuses reprises sur
cette place de la rep de la bastille
pardon provoquant un épais nuage de
fumée blanche
depuis la situation s'est calmée mais il
ya quelques minutes certains
manifestants ont tenté de l'incursion
tenter de reprendre une forme de
manifestation sauvage comme ils la
décrivent ils ont été empêchés par les
forces de l'ordre des gendarmes en
l'occurrence qui sont disposés un peu
partout vous allez le voir sur ces
images de citer lauvergeon les gendarmes
mobiles qui sont disposés sur les abords
de cette place de la bastille pour
encadrer véritablement cette
manifestation et toute tentative de la
part des manifestants bien de prendre
une rue pour poursuivre la manifestation
et veine puisqu'il faisons face à eux un
important dispositif de police on attend
et de gendarmes aussi donc on attend
maintenant l'évolution
il ya parfois des regains de d'énergie
on va dire de la part des manifestants
qui entament des slogans mais à l'heure
où je vous parle dans un moment plutôt
calmes où les personnes sont plutôt
statique sur cette place de la bastille
alors dans ce cortège de manifestants il
ya donc des membres du personnel
soignant qu'on souhaitait faire entendre
leurs revendications notamment sur le
manque de moyens et ne sont pas
convaincus par les conclusions du ségur
de la santé qui a été signée hier il
dénonce aussi le fait que certains
syndicats n'ont pas signé cet accord et
puis le fait que certains syndicats ne
sont pas forcément très heureux
représentatif de la base du personnel
hospitalier qui réclame encore davantage
au jeu propose d'écouter le témoignage
de personnes qui sont originaires de
normandie et qui ont fait le déplacement
à paris pour cet événement aujourd'hui
un cirage de pompes le passé
on va embellir la chose on veut comment
nous faire croire plein de choses et
puis que derrière on rigole un petit peu
on fait des pieds de nez aux to the
hospital où jean spitalier enfin les
personnels hospitaliers pardon donc là
on doit une petite chose pour calmer le
jeu mais quand tout sera fini mais on va
continuer le processus et on fermera les
les oreilles des demandes de tous les
gens personnel hospitalier donc voilà on
est là pour ça et que en fin de compte
qu'on arrête bas tout simplement nous
prendre pour des blaireaux en cortège
composé également de beaucoup de gilet
jaune et gilet jaune qui ont fait le
déplacement depuis plusieurs villes de
france de lyon damien ou encore de
bordeaux ils sont venus à paris pour
cette journée hautement symbolique on
est le 14 juillet jour de fête nationale
c'était important pour eux de continuer
à occuper le terrain à faire entendre
leurs revendications en dépit d'une
mobilisation qui s'est affaiblie ces
dernières semaines il ya beaucoup de
gens de province qui sont donc montés
sur vers la capitale pour garnir les
rangs des manifestants je propose
d'écouter l'un d'entre eux ne se
revendique plus vraiment comme gilet
jaune mais il a participé au premier
acte de mobilisation il est originaire
de bordeaux est au micro de cynthia
lovers alors on a toujours appelés à
converger avec avec le personnel
hospitalier
d'ailleurs nous aujourd'hui on n'est
plus chez les jeunes on est citoyen en
colère
voilà parce que ça représente toutes les
luttes et aujourd'hui c'est important de
toutes les luttes convergent ensemble je
prends par exemple les les patrons de
boîtes de nuit bas on aurait aimé
aujourd'hui que les patrons de boîtes de
nuit soit avec nous dans la rue tous
ensemble et je pense que la grande union
des luttes il faut qu'elle soit
maintenant c'est important on attend la
rentrée j'espère que les gens le reste
des gens vont se réveiller parce que
malheureusement c'est toujours les mêmes
qu'on a dans la rue et fo faut réveiller
les autres que ça soit il ya tellement
de trucs qui vont pas à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui qu'on se bat pas je trouve
pas ça normal
voilà pour les gilets jaunes qui ont
fait le déplacement pour cette journée
du 14 juillet on ait place de la
bastille c'est évidemment un acte très
symbolique et d'ailleurs les slogans
révolution sont si régulièrement scandé
par la foule dès gilet jaune qui appelle
désormais à de nouvelles mobilisations
certains jeux les jeunes avec lesquels
on a échangé également appel à reprendre
les ronds points pour cette rentrée qui
s'annonce particulièrement chargée d'un
point de vue social est resté avec nous
sur rt france on poursuit cette édition
dans quelques instants direction et les
états unis et plus précisément la
californie à l'état américain le plus
peuplé est touché de plein fouet par le
comique 19è les salles de restaurant bar
coiffeur et lieux de culte sont à
nouveau fermés à puis nous parlerons des
tensions en mer de chine le secrétaire
d'état my pop euro réaffirm l'opposition
américaine à la mainmise chinoise sur
des territoires maritimes contestées
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
si on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ceux qui six est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien janet jackson
arrow ni la gravité la date en 2000 il a
été élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie et pour le développement
global car nous avons besoin aussi
d'être en paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française le coronavirus continue sa
propagation à travers le monde les etats
unis restent le pays le plus touché par
le cos vite 19 avec plus de 135 mille
morts né près de soixante mille nouveaux
cas en 24 heures une flambée des
contaminations et qui pousse certains
états à faire marche arrière c'est le
cas de la californie le gouverneur a
ordonné hier la fermeture de certains
commerces et services
cet état le plus peuplé du pays avait
été le premier à poser un confinement
général en mars dernier clément hospital
et maxime du haschich à chaque et à sa
politique alors qu'entre les terrasses
des restaurants de miami beach en
floride le port du masque est
obligatoire en californie les mesures de
restriction sont renforcées le nombre de
cas de coronavirus continue d'exploser
l'état reste l'un des principaux foyers
d'infection dans le pays
le comté de los angeles représente
presque à lui seul la moitié des cas le
gouverneur de californie
gavin newsom ne veut pas prendre de
risque salle de restaurant bar salon de
coiffure et lieux de culte sont de
nouveau fermée au public
nous commençons à voir dans certaines
régions rurales de l'état une hausse du
recours aux unités de soins intensifs
qui suscite des inquiétudes
limitez vos interactions avec des gens
extérieurs à votre foyer
c'est juste du bon sens mais les données
suggèrent que tout le monde ne suit pas
forcément le bon sens si vous
interagissez avec des personnes
extérieures
il est important que vous le fassiez en
plein air ces restrictions concernent
environ 80% des 40 millions d'habitants
de californie les écoles de l'état ne
pourront donc pas rouvrir leurs portes
aux élèves pour la rentrée prévue le 18
août
les cours seront dispensés à distance
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
une décision qui agace donald trump pour
qui un retour à la normale l'emportent
sur les problèmes de santé publique
le président américain a ainsi déclaré
vouloir que les écoles rouvrent à
l'automne coûte que coûte
lors de sa dernière déclaration donald
trump a maintenu cette ligne et nous
testons plus que quiconque est de loin
et quand on teste on crée des cas nous
avons donc créé des cas je peux vous
dire que dans certains pays on fait des
tests lorsque quelqu'un arrive malades à
l'aube
peut-être chez le médecin mais c'est
généralement à l'hôpital ils n'ont donc
pas de cas alors que nous nous en avons
nous avons tous ces cas donc vous savez
c'est une arme à double tranchant
en même temps nous avons le taux de
mortalité le plus bas ou à peu près le
plus bas du monde comme au texas ou en
floride dans le sud et l'ouest du pays
des responsables locaux envisagent
d'aller encore plus loin et de décréter
leur confinement de la population
mais des désaccords politiques
persistent entre autorités locales et
fédérales
ce qui empêche de trouver une réponse
unifiée pour endiguer la propagation du
virus
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis atlanta aux etats-unis avec ben
swan journaliste d'investigation c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
même si one bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors la
californie un des premiers états à se
confiner début mars qui se recombinent
cinq mois plus tard
comment le comprendre le premier
confinement n'a pas été suffisamment
respectées ou c'est d'un autre ordre
c'est une très bonne question
la californie connaît une situation très
différente de certains autres états qui
ont également imposé le confinement très
tôt
la californie a mis en place un
confinement très strictes
très tôt comme le michigan new york le
new jersey l'illinois également il ya eu
des consignes très strictes les
restaurants les bars ont été fermés la
californie ne permettait même pas à ces
attentes se rendre sur les plages
d'autres états comme le texas et la
floride des états très peuplés ont dit à
nos maux de confiner assez tôt et
recommencer mais la californie n'a
jamais mis un terme à son confinement
comme par exemple texas nous avons vu
une explosion du nombre des cas au texas
et en californie
mais ce sont deux cas différents car la
californie n'a jamais autant relaxer les
consignes que par exemple le texas où la
floride
et pourtant ils ont beaucoup beaucoup de
cas donc ce que vous nous dites c'est
finalement la situation en californie ne
reflète pas la situation aux états unis
oui effectivement c'est une anomalie ce
qui se passe en californie est très
différent que ce qu'on observe dans
d'autres états très peuplées pourrait y
avoir plusieurs raisons à cela le
gouvernement californien ne permettait
pas les déplacements et publiques ne
permettait pas l'ouverture des
restaurants ou des bars mais
météo en californie et au texas est très
différente donc certaines personnes
auraient pu décider de ne pas rester
chez elle de sortir d'où cette
augmentation du nombre des cas on n'en
parle pas beaucoup mais il faut savoir
également que même s'il ya une hausse du
nombre de morts quotidien le rapport
entre les nouveaux décès et les nouveaux
cas est bien plus bas qu'ils ne
l'étaient en mars et en avril
donc même si nous avons beaucoup de
nouveaux cas le nombre de décès ne
vendent pas aussi rapidement et il
semble que la raison en soit que les
personnes plus jeunes sont concernés
plutôt par cette seconde vague alors on
en vient à ces images qui ont fait le
tour du monde à donald trump qui est
apparue avec un masque lors d'une visite
dans un hôpital militaire dans la
banlieue de washington
est-ce que selon vous cela marque une
prise de conscience du président
américain notamment dans le sillage de
jaillir ball sonar au qui a été cité qui
a été testé positif aux copies de 19
c'est une possibilité effectivement les
images ont vu le tour du monde comme
vous le dites donald trump porte un
masque
cela montre donc eu que les gens qui ont
bien réfléchi à ce mass car il est à ses
couleurs
le président et le vice-président porte
maintenant des masques alors que le
président avait beaucoup résisté à cette
idée et il ya beaucoup
un débat très important dans ce pays
entre ceux qui portent le masque et ceux
qui ne portent pas c'est vraiment le
point d'ébullition il ya beaucoup de
colère des deux côtés ici
on ne porte pas un masque les gens sont
en colère si on importe un les gens sont
également en colère et donald trump
samples décidé de se tourner vers ceux
qui portent des masques mais en tout cas
c'est base électorale est contre donc en
tout cas le fait que donald trump porte
un masque cela a eu un impact finalement
sur les citoyens américains
est-ce qu'il porte du mc c'est un peu
plus généralisée je ne sais pas si le
nombre de personnes portant le masque a
augmenté mais dans l'état de michigan
par exemple le gouverneur à instaurer
une nouvelle règle
on ne peut pas forcer les gens à le
porter mais il a exigé que tous les
commerces nécessite le port du masque
pour accueillir des clients
et sinon les commerces crise que de
perdre leur licence d'exercice donc
certains états essaient de rendre
obligatoire le port du masque mais en
géorgie à atlanta par exemple le
gouverneur porte un masque encourage la
population à le faire mais n'a pas émis
de décret pour le rendre obligatoire
donc les différents états en différentes
s'approche et une chose est certaine il
n'y a pas de stratégie unique pour le
port du masque
alors on a vu les copies de partie et
cette histoire tragique de la mort d'un
trentenaire au texas et yat-il encore
beaucoup de citoyens américains
sceptiques quant à la réalité de la
gravité du coronavirus ya effectivement
beaucoup de sceptiques aux états unis
ils remettent en question le nombre de
morts ils remettent en question l'idée
que le cours ne verserait plus dangereux
que la grippe
le problème c'est que les tests sont ne
sont pas bien mené aux états unis
n'ayant pas assez de données sur le
nombre de personnes qui
on a attrapé le corps navires us qu'elle
ait eu des symptômes ou pas donc nous ne
savons pas qui l'a eu et nous savons pas
quelles personnes sont particulièrement
vulnérables
et cela continue et plus cela continue
plus cela génère de scepticisme au sein
de la population
je pense que les gens deviennent de plus
en plus sceptique avec le temps alors
pour conclure la disparité des
politiques sanitaires entre les états
est ce qu il est là le problème majeur
aux états unis
cela fait toujours partie du problème
aux états unis il y à différents points
de vue très divergentes états unis
nous avons des équipes il faudrait
l'imaginer comme un tournoi sportif il y
à l'équipe pour le gouvernement où
l'équipe contre le gouvernement l'équipe
masque l'équipe
pas de masque et la population de se
divisent en camps s'agissant de toutes
les questions police possible car la
question est extrêmement politisée merci
beaucoup
ben swan d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
d'investigation à la mer de chine
méridionale à présent source de vives
tensions entre washington et pékin pour
le chef de la diplomatie américaine mike
pompéo à les etats-unis considèrent les
revendications territoriales de la chine
comme illégale elle pourrait
déstabiliser la région
ah les précisions de clément hospital un
hélicoptère de l'armée populaire de
libération sillonnent la cime des arbres
juste au dessus des troupes de l'armée
de terre chinoise
un exercice inhabituel par son envergure
réalisée fin juin autour des très
disputée îles paracel revendiquée par la
chine le viêtnam et taïwan mais
contrôlée par pékin
une manoeuvre militaire qu'à condamner
le secrétaire d'état américain mike
pompéo qui affirme désormais que les
revendications territoriales de pékin en
mer de chine méridionale sont contraires
au droit international
nous le disons clairement les
revendications de pékin sur les
ressources offshore dans la plus grande
partie de la merde
une méridionale sont complètement
illégal de même que sa campagne
d'intimidation pour les contrôles et les
états unis rejettent depuis un certain
temps les revendications de la chine sur
la quasi-totalité des îlots et récifs de
la mer de chine méridionale en 2016 un
tribunal de la cour permanente
d'arbitrage de la haye avait jugé que la
chine n'avait pas de base légale pour
revendiquer des droits historiques sur
cette zone après les dernières
déclarations du chef de la diplomatie
américaine
pékin accuse washington de tenter de
saper la stabilité régionale la
déclaration américaine négligent
d'histoire et les faits concernant les
questions relatives à la mer de chine
méridionale
elle viole l'engagement ouvert du
gouvernement américain de ne pas prendre
position sur la souveraineté de
l'archipel
elles défendent le droit international
attise les conflits territoriaux et
maritime pour perturber la paix la
stabilité régionale elle est très
irresponsable au fond afin de maintenir
la pression sur la chine les etats unis
conduisent régulièrement des manoeuvres
aéronavales en mer de chine méridionale
de son côté pékin a considérablement
renforcé sa flotte ces dernières années
avec plus de 600 navires de combat c'est
désormais la 2e marine de guerre au
monde derrière l' us navy et pour en
parler nous femmes grecques françois
durpaire spécialiste des états unis
françois durpaire merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors pour
commencer peut-être se rappelle pourquoi
washington est particulièrement attentif
à ce qui se passe en mer de chine
méridionale et ses dix questions de
évidemment de puissance et de
d'opposition entre les deux simplement
ce qu'il faut souligner c'est que ça
fait penser un peu historiquement vous
savez à la fin du 19e siècle
on parlait de la volonté des états unis
de d'écarter toutes les puissances du du
de la sphère américaine vous rappelez
peut-être de la doctrine monroe du
corollaire roosevelt à la doctrine
monroe et c'est ce qu'ils essayent de
faire la chine en dix ans
touchez pas à l'asile à la vie c'est la
sphère d'influencé de la chine il ya
quand même une grande différence c'est
que les états unis ont des alliés dans
la région
brunei la malaisie les philippines
taiwan le vietnam ont aussi des
revendications dans la mer de chine
méridionale et tous ces états sont des
alliés des etats unis
donc évidemment la chine est quand même
géographiquement plus embêté et sur le
plan géostratégique plus embêté que ne
l'étaient les états unis à la fin du 19e
siècle alors en tout cas sur ce dossier
la position des états unis a toujours
été la même néanmoins comment comprendre
ce changement de ton qui semble plus
ferme finalement qu'auparavant abc est
sans doute à comprendre aussi dans le
cadre de l'élection américaine donald
trump aujourd'hui veut donner des gages
à son électorat il a fait sa campagne
pour vous rappeler sur son opposition
avec la chine il a même dit que son
adversaire
joe biden était l'ami des chinois ça
n'aurait pas de sens de faire cette
campagne ci lui était aussi la vie des
chinois dont il a besoin
quand même quatre mois avant l'élection
et vous verrez que la situation ne
s'améliorera pas d'ici le 3 novembre
prochain
et bien sûr un certain nombre de
dossiers vous savez la mairie de nice
est un des dossiers mais il y en a bien
d'autres d'opposition avec la chaîne
peut évidemment citer la 5g
on peut citer hong kong on peut citer la
bière commercial qui continue et donc il
ya un certain temps une certain nombre
d'oppositions un certain nombre de
dossiers qui évidemment sont très
tendues aujourd'hui entre les deux
premières puissances mondiales
mais finalement on quoi être anti
chinois finalement ça rapporte des voix
de la halle trump
si vous voulez donald trump il a
construit sa campagne électorale sur le
nationaliste sur un nouveau nationaliste
faire d'eux des états unis un pays à
nouveau puissante sébum son slogan
électoral alors cela dit vous savez
c'est c'est dans la tête de donald trump
c'est peut-être comme s'il avait
peut-être pris pour acquis le fait que
la chine était une puissance qui allait
continuer à progresser et à prendre la
place des états unis c'est pas sûr du
tout et au moins il ya 3 d à trois
données contente on ne parle presque
jamais la première c'est désormais la
fragilité démographique le
vieillissement de lâcher de lâcher le
baptême 400 millions de travailleurs au
cours du prochain siècle
la deuxième chose c'est bien les marchés
d'exportation la chine dépend des
marchés d'exportation dépend à 15% de
l'europe
or l'europe est aujourd'hui est bien un
marché moribond un espace moribond sur
le plan économique les états unis 19 %
pour les exportations chinoises et
baisse de 17% depuis l'été 2010 8
jusqu'à janvier 2020 et surtout la
faiblesse de la chine sur le plan
géographique et géostratégique dont je
parle et vous savez la chine dépend de
dieu du golfe pour son pétrole de
l'afrique pour ses ressources et pour
ses exportations en grande partie aussi
de l'europe
et bien c'est trois zones sont contrôlés
par la marine américaine le contrôle des
mers c'est toujours le contrôle du monde
et vous voyez il ya peut-être encore un
temps on parle souvent de des états unis
qui vont devenir la deuxième puissance
du monde derrière la chine vient
peut-être que tous tous ces
développements actuels montrent que les
états unis ont peut être encore de
longues années devant elle c'est
toujours la première puissance du monde
grâce à sa marraine
alors en tout cas la tension monte
de plus en plus avec l'envoi de deux
porte-avions américain est ce qu'on peut
craindre une escalade aujourd'hui alors
oui vous savez ce que développe ce qui
se développe beaucoup aux états unis
s'est vidée d'une guerre possible tout
simplement entre la chine et les états
unis et ont ces références souvent le
spécialiste de la diplomatie au piège de
thucydide qu'est ce que ça veut dire
la guerre du péloponnèse vous vous en
souvenez peut-être du côté de la
puissance émergente c'est-à-dire
d'athènes vous avez la chine et du côté
de sparte vous avez des états unis la
thèse de 7,2 cette idée de thucydide
c'est qu'il ya forcément un conflit
entre les deux puissances ne s'est pas
sûr du tout et pour trois raisons très
rapidement la première c'est que la
chine n'a pas nécessairement de
velléités militaire à l'extérieur de la
mer de chine méridionale
c'est pas du tout la volonté de la chine
de dominer le monde militairement
la deuxième raison c'est évidemment
l'interdépendance économique entre les
deux états qui ont tellement tellement
d'intérêts en commun qu'on voit pas
pourquoi il se ferait la guerre et puis
la troisième raison c'est que notamment
par vous savez le projet des routes de
la soie
la chine va rogner sur des territoires
et des intérêts que les états unis ont
déjà mis de côté on prenez l'exemple de
la spec évidemment la chine aujourd'hui
est omniprésente en afrique mais les
états unis sont déjà fin on n'en pas
besoin de la chine pour être absente de
ces territoires là donc pour ces trois
raisons au moins
probablement c'est une analyse et cd que
la mienne
la guerre entre la chine et les états
unis n'aura probablement jamais lieu
merci beaucoup ont donc à françois
durpaire pour votre analyse je rappelle
que vous êtes historien spécialiste des
états-unis le royaume-uni exclu huawei
de son réseau 5g le gouvernement
britannique a confirmé l'interdiction de
tout nouvel achat d'équipement du géant
chinois après le 31 décembre 2020 à une
décision qui cristallise un peu plus les
tensions entre pékin et londres à
cyrielle bruit
nouveau coup de tonnerre powell après
une réunion du conseil de sécurité
nationale présidé par boris johnson
le royaume uni a fait le choix d'exclure
le géant chinois de son réseau 5 g selon
le ministre britannique chargé de la
culture et du numérique
cette décision a pour but de sécuriser
le réseau du pays le gouvernement est
d'accord avec l'avis du centre nationale
de cybersécurité
la meilleure façon de sécuriser nos
réseaux et que les opérateurs cesse
d'utiliser les nouveaux équipements de
huawei concernés pour construire les
futurs réseaux 5g du royaume uni donc
pour être clair à partir de la fin de
cette année les opérateurs de
télécommunications ne doivent plus
acheter des équipements 5 ga huawei et
une fois que la loi sur la sécurité des
télécommunications sera adopté il sera
illégal pour eux de le faire
une décision influencé par les sanctions
américaines contre le géant chinois en
mai dernier les états unis ont prolongé
d'un an l'embargo empêchant huawei de
collaborer avec des entreprises
américaines
avant même l'annoncé de londres la chine
a réagi ce mardi à une éventuelle mesure
punitive britannique nouveau la question
de savoir si le royaume uni peut offrir
un environnement commercial ouvert
équitable et non discriminatoire aux
entreprises chinoises sera la pierre de
touche de la tendance du marché
britannique après brixi ainsi qu'un
baromètre de la sécurité des
investissements chinois au royaume uni
la chine y prêtera une attention
particulière des paroles lourdes de sens
qui laisse entrevoir une riposte de la
part de pékin
les tensions ne cessent de monter entre
les deux pays notamment au sujet de hong
kong en cause
l'entrée en vigueur d'une loi de
sécurité contesté dans le territoire
semi autonome début juillet boris
johnson a confirmé son intention de
permettre à des hong kong et de
s'installer pendant au moins cinq ans au
royaume uni reste eric naulleau sur rt
france dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur l'interview d'emmanuel
macron en ce 14
juillet le plan de relance de l'économie
française représentera au moins 100
milliards d'euros promet-il avec la
jeunesse comme priorité et puis nous
parlerons des manifestations des
soignants et des gilets jaunes cet après
midi contre les accords du ségur de la
santé et le gouvernement rester avec
nous sur rt france
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
du dernier rapport du giec sur les
océans
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parcomètres de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui conteste normes six
personnes non non c'est pas vrai il ya
des climats tous et non ce n'est pas
rien a pas il ya des gens qui ne sont
pas des chercheurs qui parlent que la
presse met en avant parce que il faut
que du débat le gars plus de débats
aujourd'hui ya plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique et on va faire un
vrai par une catastrophe ou 20 vers une
vraie catastrophe et on est incapable
d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y'en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
et
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis
promise par renoncer aux soins vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck ça que ça
veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
pour construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
pourquoi une banque disparaîtrait pas
pourquoi pas bien sûr la banque ne gagne
pas d'argent sur son métier traditionnel
mais gagne de l'argent uniquement sur
des opérations marche deux mois de non
consommation mondiale et les plus gros
groupe s'arrête et 10 on n'a pas de
trésorerie
c'est un modèle assez extraordinaire à
la banque c'est à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant c'était privatisation des
gains et mutualisation des pertes donc
en fait c'est fâcheux gagne pile tu
perds ont créé une économie qui l'a zéro
valeur
statistiquement vous aurez une banque en
europe une banque majeur en europe qui
socrates
[Musique]
la crise du corona virus s'aggrave en
amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien janet jackson
arrow ni la gravité de la pandémie il a
été élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie et pour le développement
global car nous avons besoin aussi
d'être en paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les deux types préoccupe
bien avant que le match ne commence en
effet par sénégal la chloroquine
domaniale utilisé pendant des décennies
et des décennies ça pourrait perdurer
les sénégalais quand j'entendais il n'y
a pas de signes qui mettent en doute ces
protocoles
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre lé musée avec trois mois de nos
activités ou les billetteries sont à
l'arrêt l'impact financier est énorme
ce sera un redémarrage sous conditions 1
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021 il faudra
reconstruire le marché se reprendre à
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre sur rt france pour une heure
d'information il est 21h heure de paris
tout de suite c'est les titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 14 juillet 2000
le chef de l'état a accepté de se
soumettre pour la première fois depuis
son élection à la traditionnelle
interview du 14 juillet il a notamment
détaillé son plan d'action contre la
crise avec la jeunesse comme priorité de
cette relance
mais cette prise de parole et les
célébrations du jour n'ont pas suffi à
calmer l'ardeur de la rue est des
soignants et des gilets jaunes ont
manifesté tout au long de la journée
quelques heurts avec les forces de
l'ordre ont eu lieu dans la capitale
[Musique]
emmanuel macron veut que le port du
masque soit obligatoire dans tous les
lieux publics à partir du 1er août par
ailleurs le chef de l'état la firme le
pays est prêt en cas de deuxième vague
alors que les contaminations repartent à
la hausse
et du côté du monde de la nuit c'est la
douche froide le conseil d'état rejette
la demande de réouverture des
discothèques
[Musique]
le sommet européen des luttes dans trois
jours il devra trancher sur un plan de
relance de 750 milliards d'euros et les
chefs d'état sont déjà à la manoeuvre
emmanuel macron recevra demain à
l'elysée le chef du gouvernement
espagnol pedro sanchez puis jeudi le
premier ministre suédois stefan lofven à
des rencontres dans un contexte tendu en
gala merkel s'est dit hier incertaine
sur la possibilité de trouver un accord
entre eux est les dirigeants à des vingt
sept
[Musique]
est la fête nationale dans le siège de
la crise sanitaire a donc été marquée
par une cérémonie inédite en hommage aux
soignants mais aussi par l'interview
télévisée d'emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état a finalement accepté de se plier
aux traditionnels entretiens du 14
juillet avec crise sanitaire économique
et social il a fait le tour de
l'actualité
à moins de deux ans de la fin de son
mandat et parmi les annonces celle du
port du masque dans les lieux publics
clos
il devrait être obligatoire dès le 1er
août et puis un plan de relance massif
avec une priorité pour la jeunesse
devrait atteindre selon emmanuel macron
au moins 100 milliards d'euros en plus
de l'argent déjà milliers on le disait
les soignants mise à l'honneur
aujourd'hui vous avez pu suivre la
cérémonie place de la concorde à paris
en direct sur rt france à mais cet
hommage est loin d'être suffisant pour
certains personnels hospitaliers mais
six organisations syndicales ont appelé
à une mobilisation nationale aujourd'hui
émaillé de quelques tensions
elle estime que le gouvernement
méprisent leurs métiers leurs
revendications à les précisions de notre
reporter thomas bowness près de 18
heures et les forces de l'ordre demande
conduisent les
manifestants à quitter les lieux vous
allez voir sur ces images ils ont
refermé la nasse le cercle qu'ils
forment autour des manifestants pour les
conduire vers le métro ici à bastille
pour qu'ils quittent les lieux et vous
le voyez il ya encore un peu d'ambiance
un peu de manifestants qui continuent à
scander en l'occurrence des champs de
gilet jaune à l'image de cette
manifestation
beaucoup de gilet jaune ont fait le
déplacement cet après midi manifestation
aussi pour le personnel soignant on a
interrogé des personnes qui sont venus
de normandie pour manifester aujourd'hui
vous propose de les écouter un cirage de
pompes ins et on va embellir la chose on
veut comment nous faire croire plein de
choses et puis que derrière on rigole un
petit peu on fait des pieds de nez aux
to the hospital aux gens spitalier enfin
les le personnel hospitalier pardon donc
là on doit d'une petite chose pour
calmer le jeu mais quand tout sera fini
et ben on va continuer le processus et
on fermera les les oreilles des demandes
de tous les gens personnel hospitalier
donc voilà on est là pour ça et que en
fin de compte qu'on arrête bas tout
simplement nous prendre pour des
blaireaux
je vous le disais beaucoup de gilet
jaune qui ont fait le déplacement des
jeunes originaires de plusieurs villes
de province on a rencontré des gilet
jaune damien de lyon ou encore de
bordeaux comme la personne que vous
allez entendre qui a fait le déplacement
spécialement aujourd'hui en cette
journée du 14 juillet jour de fête
nationale c'est très important pour lui
de continuer à porter ces revendications
je propose de l'écouter au micro de
cynthia l'auberge
on a toujours appelés à converger avec
avec le personnel hospitalier
d'ailleurs nous nous aujourd'hui on
n'est plus chez les jeunes on est
citoyen en colère
voilà parce que ça représente toutes les
luttes et aujourd'hui c'est important de
toutes les luttes convergent ensemble je
prends par exemple les
les patrons de boîte de nuit on aurait
aimé aujourd'hui que les patrons de
boîtes de nuit soit avec nous dans la
rue tous ensemble et je pense que la
grande union des luttes il faut qu'elle
soit maintenant c'est important on
attend la rentrée j'espère que les gens
le reste des gens vont se réveiller
parce que malheureusement c'est toujours
les mêmes qu'on a qu'on a dans la rue et
fo faut réveiller les autres que ça soit
il ya tellement de trucs qui vont pas à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui qu'on se bat pas
je trouve pas ça normal
manifestation donc avec quelques
tensions lorsque le cortège est arrivé
sur la place de la bastille il faut dire
que le dispositif de sécurité était
particulièrement massif des forces de
l'ordre parfois très proche des
manifestants et des tensions donc
pendant la marche qui est partie de la
place de la république jusqu'à la place
de la bastille tension aussi sur cette
place ou du gaz lacrymogènes notamment a
été utilisé à de nombreuses reprises
voilà pour cette manifestation et les
gilet jaune avec un regain d'activité
suite à des mobilisations un peu plus
faible ces dernières semaines ils
appellent pour certains d'entre eux à
reprendre les ronds points dans un
premier temps et a multiplié les actions
dans un temps un plus large d'ici la
rentrée notamment au mois de septembre
et pour revenir sur les principales
annonces des manuels macron nous sommes
avec benjamin cauchy porte parole de
debout la france etc ce gilet jaune et
puis clément armato porte parole de
l'uni l'union nationale inter
universitaire est également avec nous
messieurs bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
alors clément armato je me tourne vers
vous en effet emmanuel macron noir
annoncé des mesures pour la jeunesse
comme des exonérations de charges pour
les jeunes diplômés ou la mise en place
de trois cent mille contrats d'insertion
on regarde et on en parle juste après
nous allons avoir un dispositif
exceptionnel d'exonération des charges
pour les jeunes en particulier pour les
faibles qualifications
il y aura trois cent mille projets
d'insertion pour les jeunes qui n'ont
pas trouvé d'entreprise
clément armato vous êtes satisfait par
ces annonces du président alors comme
dhabi comme d'habitude avec emmanuel
macron on n'attendait pas grand chose
mais on est quand même déçu
c'est cette annonce d'exonération des
charges est bien plus faible que celle
qui avait été défendue par les députés
il ya quelques jours et qui a été rejeté
par la majorité présidentielle
et on le voit cette exonération de
charges
prend pas en compte les 700 mille
diplômés de l'enseignement supérieur qui
vont arriver sur le marché d'emploi dès
septembre de plus les trois cent mille
contrats aidés c'est un retour aux
emplois d'avenir la vieille recette
socialiste quand il ya une crise et donc
créer des emplois d'avenir financés par
des impôts et par de la dette et donc ce
n'est pas ça qui crée des emplois ce
n'est pas ça qui relancent l'économie et
ce n'est pas ça qui va créer une
situation stable pour ces jeunes
benjamin cauchy vous comprenez c'est ta
déception après ces annonces alors que
la jeunesse a été annoncé comme étant
prioritaire dans le plan de relance
économique des manuels macron oui
absolument on peut comprendre le
désappointement de du représentant de
l'une des meilleures syndicat l'un des
meilleurs syndicat étudiant qui puisse
exister en france et qui a dressé un
constat parfaitement lucide j'ai
souvenir quand j'étais étudiant qu'il y
avait à l'époque les emplois jeunes qui
a été finalement une fausse bonne idée
puisque pendant près de cinq ans des
gens travailler et non absolument non
absolument pas plus pardon cotiser pour
leur retraite donc faut faire attention
à ces faux emplois qui ne résolvent pas
le problème
en revanche moi j'attendais de la part
du président macro et bien qu'ils
proposent une année blanche sur un plan
fiscal et social pour l'ensemble des
entreprises françaises et je pense
notamment et j'ai vu votre reportage sur
les patrons discothèque sur les
cafetiers sur les hôteliers qui sont en
train de souffrir grandement et qui sont
eux le générateur de véritables en quoi
donc encore une fois emmanuel macron
bien sûr sa poudre de perlimpinpin mais
ne répond pas aux vrais problèmes
alors on vous a entendu à faire l'éloge
de l'union peut le dire vous êtes tous
les deux a ancré à droite et pour
certains le gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron lui aussi penché à droite le
président s'en est défendu on regarde le
gouvernement aujourd'hui constitué est
un gouvernement qui a des femmes et des
hommes qui viennent de la droite comme
de la gauche et à peu près autant d'un
côté comme de l'autre
alors pour vous qu'en est -il est ce que
le gouvernement macron penche à droite
ou pas clément rama tôt alors non
clairement le gouvernement de la crau
comme depuis le début de son quinquennat
pentu tour à gauche on le voit sa
majorité présidentielle est composée
d'anciens socialistes
si on prend gabriela talent c'est un
ancien socialiste
et c'est donc c'est pas parce qu'on
prend 2,3 personnes de droite que ça va
faire un gouvernement de droite
la preuve en est sarkozy a fait
l'ouverture à gauche ça ne pas
sanctionner ça n'a fait que tu es déçu
eh bien c'est exactement pareil pour
emmanuel macron doux à droite nous ne
soutenons pas ses ministres qu'ils vont
faire le spot est la rythmique en marche
alors un nouveau show ma benjamin cauchy
annoncée par le président tout cas un
nouveau chemin qui part pas à droite non
plus pour vous non mais écoutez moi
quand je prends un chemin je préfère
avoir un guide de randonnée plutôt qu'un
président de la république qui est en
train de nous mener droit dans le ravin
clairement pour moi ce gouvernement lit
n'est ni de droite ni de gauche il est
europe et east et il a su rassembler
autour de lui des gens des républicains
comme darmanin comme monsieur castex
comme lé pape edouard philippe comme
monsieur le maire et comme bien d'autres
et puis la rue ni effectivement des gens
de gauche mal en point commun ces
lettres d euros pays c'est à dire qu'ils
ont donné les clés la france à l'union
européenne est donc aujourd'hui le
clivage pour moi n'est plus droite
gauche
aujourd'hui le clivage il est entre ceux
qui ont donné les clés de la maison
france à l'union européenne et ceux qui
veulent récupérer ses clés pour sauver
la france et redevenir maître de son
destin et clément amato est ce que les
clés elles ont été donné un petit peu à
la jeunesse aujourd'hui ou par par le
président emmanuel macron avec les
mesures alors non pas du tout aux clics
les n'a été donnée à la jeunesse au
contraire et manuel da cruz vous retire
des clés de plus en plus nous faire des
portes puisqu'il n'y a aucune réforme de
fond est structurelle depuis le début de
son quinquennat
ce ne sont que des mesurettes sont que
des petites réformettes
il n'y a aucun projet sur le long terme
on le voit au sein d'enseignement
supérieur nous avons été pendant cette
crise les grands oubliés de la crise
sanitaire et du confinement à cause
d'une ministre qui est inexistante
d'ailleurs il a eu un mot pour la
rentrée des classes
pas pour les facultés est-ce que vous
avez une vision pour la rentrée
prochaine
alors non nous n'avons aucune vision
pour la rentrée nous avons à l'heure
actuelle ministère qui est aux abonnés
absents depuis le début du confinement
il ne répond à aucune question il na vi
à vue il a totalement abandonné tous les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
qui doit se débrouiller
on a une ministre qui il ya quelques
temps disait qu'il fallait faire du
distant ciel à la rentrée et qui hier
vient d'annoncer que dan harel était
100% pour le présentiel donc en fait ils
naviguent totalement à vue les étudiants
sont très inquiet et on se dirige quand
même vers une situation très très
compliqué surtout quand on sait que nous
aurons cent mille bacheliers de plus à
la rentrée quel soir j'irai alors
inquiétudes des étudiants vous n'êtes
pas les seuls on a vu les manifestations
à cet après midi le président s'est
d'ailleurs exprimé sur les comportements
dans les manifestations je vous propose
de regarder je crois que la haine n'est
pas acceptable en démocratie et la haine
dans le discours et la violence dans les
manifestations ne peuvent être acceptés
benjamin cauchy en tant qu'ex le gilet
jaune
est-ce que vous rejoignez les propos du
président sur les violences dans les
manifestations comme savez les violences
moi je comprends que les français sont à
bout les français sont à bout parce que
il ya plus de 18 mois des gens de tout
horizon politique des gens de toutes
origines sociales de toutes classes
professionnelles s'était réuni dans la
rue pour demander plus de justice
sociale et plus de justice fiscale
juste avant cette crise du coc vide qui
évidemment rebat les cartes
aucune réponse n'a été apportée lerrick
n'a pas été mis en place
aucune réforme constitutionnelle pour
mettre en place une dose de
proportionnelle comme le propose debout
la france à hauteur de 25%
rien n'a été fait pour la baisse de la
tva sur les produits de première
nécessité donc on comprend qu'il ya une
colère latente et donc le fait que
emmanuel macron prétexte que la crise du
coc vide doit nous permettre de faire
des réformes qu'ils sont
bien comment dirais-je conséquence de
casse sociale bien évidemment je peux
comprendre la colère maintenant la
colère ne justifie en rien la violence
que ce soit la violence à la fois des
black blocs qui viennent salir les
mouvements et les manifestations d'aidés
soignants aujourd'hui mais que ce soit
également une attitude comme dirait du
gouvernement inadmissible et qui
manipulent les phases tort les forces de
l'ordre et qui demande aux forces de
l'ordre d'agir très rapidement avec des
gaz lacrymogènes c'est absolument
incroyable donc emmanuel macron à soi
disant changer de chemin d'un côté c'est
un chemin qui est pavée pavé de gaz
lacrymogènes clément armato sur ces
manifestations qui ont lieu encore cet
après midi dès gilet jaune mais aussi
des soignants votre réaction
on comprend la colère des français on
peut voir la même colère chez les jeunes
aussi
il ya une colère qui monte de plus en
plus mais cela ne justifie en rien les
violences
on le voit souvent ces manifestations en
fait sont récupérés par alex trimble ex
timbers qu'on croise dans les
universités est ce qu'un gosse que le
gouvernement laisse prospérer et laisse
s'entraîner dans les universités
aujourd'hui la vraie problématique elle
est là c'est qu'il ya une arrière base
qui permet à ces mouvements d'extrême
gauche de s'entraîner se préparer au
combat alors pour parer à toutes ces
vielles à toutes ces violences le
président a également annoncé le port de
caméras pour tous les policiers lors de
manifestations regarder nous allons
généraliser avant la fin du quinquennat
les caméras piétons pour rétablir la
confiance entre la population et la
police
une bonne idée benjamin cauchy écouter
est ce que vous croyez sincèrement
qu'une caméra sur un policier va faire
que les gens qui vivent dans les
banlieues se vivent
concrètement et correctement est ce que
vous croyez que si des policiers avaient
mis des caméras sur leur uniforme il
hier il n'y aurait pas eu de bus brûlé à
nanterre est ce que vous croyez que le
chauffeur de bus à bayonne n'aurait pas
été assassinés est ce que vous croyez
qu'il eut à namur est pas de d'horreur
et de drames au quotidien non
sérieusement je pense encore une fois
que c'est du marketing
emmanuel macron n'est là ne sais faire
que ça de toute façon c'est de la
communication
alors peut-être qu'il y a à l'exception
et à la marge et on le regrette
évidemment comme icare quelques corriger
des policiers qui font du zèle ou qui
exagèrent dans le traitement des
interpellations mais je crois que c est
caché c'est un arbre qui cache la forêt
d'une d'une grande majorité de policiers
qui fait parfaitement son boulot
en revanche je préférais qu emmanuel
macron s'attelle aux racailles parce que
la racaille tués dans le pays je crois
qu'il faut vraiment insister là dessus
alors autre question abordée par le chef
de l'état l'écologie est un qui était au
coeur du nouveau chemin a voulu par le
président et à référendum le plus vite
possible sur l'inscription de l'écologie
dans la constitution
beaucoup de jeunes apportent cette
question de l'écologie
est ce que pour vous c'est un enjeu
majeur clément armato alors au niveau de
la jeunesse il faut bien prendre en
compte que les jeunes qu'on voit se
mobiliser ce sont toujours les mêmes
ce sont des jeunes qui sont ultra
politisé et généralement peu utilisé à
koch à l'extrême-gauche ya évidemment le
sujet l'écologie est un sujet important
pour l'avenir est important chez les
jeunes
mais ce n'est absolument pas le sujet
prioritaire aujourd'hui chez les jeunes
ils veulent en parler ils veulent
trouver des solutions mais des frais
solution pas la décroissance pas une
écologie punitive pas qu'on les empêche
de rouler qu'on ne les empêche
d'utiliser en voiture qu'on les empêche
de prendre l'avion
non ils veulent une écologie humaine une
écologique intelligente un référendum le
plus vite possible sur l'inscription
l'écologie dans la constitution ça vous
semble important c'est une idée que vous
pourriez porter benjamin cauchy en tant
que porte parole de debout la france
mais écouter s'il devait y avoir un
référendum avec une thématique
écologique je croise très demandés aux
français s'ils souhaitent
oui ou non que la france sorte des
traités de libre échange qui pour le
mettre des millions de containers tous
les ans sur sur les océans et qui
fragilise à ce que les français sont
pour ou contre les éoliennes qui tue la
faune et qui abîme la fleur est ce que
vous croyez sincèrement que cette
convention citoyenne à servir à quelque
chose
moi quand je vois les mesures qui ont
été prises par exemple qu'il faut
désarmer les véhicules de collection il
considère que les véhicules anciens sont
des sons des armes qui lui convient de
désarmer voilà l'exemple et pour moi le
ridicule de cette convention citoyenne
dont quatre jours ou là des choses
concrètes à savoir à 20 ans les traits
de libre échange que les légions les
circuits courts et ça je ne pense pas
que ça nécessite du référendum et du
courage politique encore faut-il qu
emmanuel macron monde
alors bien évidemment la crise sanitaire
également avec le port du masque
obligatoire dans les lieux publics clos
à partir du 1er août on en parle
beaucoup
le chef de l'état qui assure que tout
est prêt dans le cas d'une seconde vague
vous le croyez clément amato forcément
non on le prend pas comment il a géré la
première sac
cette endémie ne peux pas croire que 16e
ça surtout cool lui permettre à lui au
gouvernement de mieux se préparer à une
seconde vague de tirer les leçons de
confinement [ __ ] et tous les indicateurs
sont en train un petit peu de repasser
au rouge dans le voit plusieurs articles
parlent nombreux cas à marseille dans le
sud
et pourtant emmanuel macron on annonce
que le masque obligatoire à partir du
1er août soit dans quinze jours que
d'ici là la situation peut très
largement empirer donc on le voit il se
laisse il pense encore avoir le temps et
que ça pourra se gérer très rapidement
comme d'habitude ils pensent que c'est
la start-up d'etion et qu'il suffit
d'appuyer sur un bouton
c'est vrai effectivement pourquoi dans
quinze jours benjamin cauchy ça aurait
pu être plus rapide selon vous cette
obligation de port de masques dans les
lieux publics clos
je pense qu'il doit y avoir une la seule
raison pour moi qui puisse être rentable
c'est le fait que
le caractère obligatoire du port du
masque doit nécessiter le fait de donner
des masques de façon gratuite à des gens
qui n'en ont pas les moyens
et donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu emmanuel macron n'avait absolument
pas préparé une deuxième vague n'avait
absolument pas prévu qu'il faille donner
des masques de façon d y imposer le
masque de façon obligatoire dans
l'ensemble du pays
parce que si ça avait été le cas il
aurait déjà prévu les acheminements de
masques pour les personnes qui n'ont pas
les moyens de s'en acheter
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
si bien des gens les fans d' emmanuel
macron les électeurs du manuel macron il
en reste et veulent attendre le 1er août
et bien et bien leur en soi mais en tout
cas j'invite chaque français à prendre
sa responsabilité et dans l'ubs donne
dans les lieux clos la sncf l'imposent
déjà avant lorsque vous prenez un train
lorsque vous rentrez dans une gare quand
j'étais hier gare du nord on impose de
porter le masque
donc j'invite les français à ne pas
attendre énormément du d'emmanuel macron
mais de se prémunir de tout danger de
porter un masque si ils peuvent s'en
acheter évidemment en tout cas une
gestion d'une éventuelle seconde vague
une relance économique avec un nouveau
gouvernement
le chef de l'état on a également parlé
il a il s'est arrêté un sur le casting
du gouvernement notamment sur le cas de
gérald darmanin on le sait une
nomination à comprise notamment par les
féministes avec une affaire de viol un
qui suit de très près le ministre de
l'intérieur emmanuel macron défend je
cite la présomption d'innocence contre
la démocratie d'opinion ce sont ces mots
vous rejoignez cette vision benjamin
cauchy 1b écoutez monsieur monsieur
darmana et est accusée menem n'a pas
encore aujourd'hui de culpabilité sur le
dos pour autant je trouve que sur un
plan politique au delà du jugement il ya
quand même des symboles et c'est vrai
qu'il paraît plus que délicat d'avoir à
la tête du ministère de l'intérieur une
personne qui est suspecté de viol voilà
ce que je peux vous dire je ne dirais
pas plus la sphère est en cours il ya
déjà eu des non lieu de prononcer mais
c'est vrai que ça crée quand même un
certain malaise et lorsque manuel macron
revendique de mettre la cause
des femmes en haut de ses priorités
ça serait quand même un malaise et on
peut se demander si des femmes battues
des femmes maltraitées vont encore avoir
le courage de franchir les portes d'un
commissariat lorsqu'il ya des suspicions
sur le premier flic de france clément en
bateau c'est le bon casting ce
gouvernement pour faire face finalement
une éventuelle seconde vague on le
disait pour enclencher le plan de
relance selon vous c'est surtout pour
l'instant un casting people un casting
qui permet de faire parler de ce
paiement dans les médias la plupart des
ministres juste changé de portefeuille
et ministère ça reste elle même équipe
au fond et seulement un tiers du
gouvernement a été renouvelé
c'est pas vraiment le remaniement alors
pour conclure là après l'autre interrogé
à plusieurs reprises sur sa volonté de
se présenter pour un second mandat
emmanuel macron a balayé je cite une
question intempestives il a parlé d'une
vision à 10 ans pour autant est-ce que
vous avez aussi entendu le candidat à la
prochaine élection
clément armato oui bien évidemment ce
discours était un discours de casse
d'une personne qui veut être candidate
mais bon ça serait mieux pour la france
et que les français qui se termine en
son mandat se termine en 2022 en 2022
faudra mettre fin à l'expérience m'a
promis benjamin cauchy le mot de la fin
non bien écoutez moi je me souviens que
en 2015
françois hollande était encore
prédisposés être candidat en 2017 vous
connaissez la suite de l'histoire donc
assises annuelles macron a des ambitions
présidentielles et bien tant mieux pour
lui en tout état de cause moi je peux
vous assurer que chez debout la france
on se prépare à ce que les républicains
les patriotes et tous ceux qui aiment la
france fasse barrage non seulement
emmanuel macron met à gagner et à faire
en sorte que l'on change enfin logiciels
et enfin de systèmes dans ce pays merci
à tous les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation benjamin cauchy je rappelle
que vous êtes porte parole de debout la
france écrit au gilet jaune à clément
armato merci à vous vous êtes
porte-parole de l'uni c'est l'union
nationale inter universitaire c'était il
ya quatre ans jour pour jour l'attentât
meurtrier à nice qui a coûté la vie à 86
personnes
toute la journée la ville a rendu
hommage à ces victimes
premier temps fort ce matin avec une
cérémonie de recueillement sans public
en raison de la crise sanitaire je vous
propose le témoignage de christine qui a
perdu son père lors de ce drame
elle se trouvait avec son compagnon
didier pendant l'attend pas isabelle
ferrières et emilie qoqa ch
quatre ans après christine est toujours
sous le choc
[Musique]
le 14 juillet 2016 elle se trouvait sur
la promenade des anglais à nice avec son
époux didier on a marché un petit peu et
là on a senti quelques gouttes qui
tombaient avec un petit vent donc on a
décidé de rentrer on a fait demi tour et
c'est là qu'on a vu des gens courir dans
tous les sens et tout d'un coup j'ai vu
un policier municipal qui sortait son
nom pour pour viser le camion on alloue
lequel n'ont qu'à rêver se faire tirer
dessus les parents de custine avait fini
par sortir plus tard de leur côté si sa
mère claude a survécu son père est lui
décédé à 78
il a fallu du temps avant de le
retrouver à la suite du drame
jean-pierre avaient déjà été transportés
à l'hôpital là on a de nouveau
donner de nouveaux l'identité de mon
père nous a fait passer par voir une
personne qui nous a dit qu'effectivement
il y avait toujours un homme inconnu
sans nom qui répondait pas dans le coma
et donc on l'a pas reconnu tellement
qu'il était défigurée c'est grâce à un
test adn que christine aura finalement
la confirmation qu'il s'agit bien de son
père grièvement blessé il est décédé
plus d'un mois après l'attentât
avec le traumatisme de la mort d'un
parent
ce sont aussi des images terribles qui
viennent hanter cette famille en
particulier sa mère aujourd'hui âgée de
85 ans il lui est toujours impossible de
parler de cette soirée
parce que au départ c'était très
compliqué quand même parce qu'elle a été
aussi renversé et ses recours elle avait
longtemps des cauchemars des personnes
amadieu jeu y avait sept personnes à
côté de moi qui avait la tête dans le
caniveau la tête ans enfin pouvez quand
même des images assez fort qui était
difficile et donc en étant tous ensemble
c'est vrai que c'est quand même plus
facile aussi de remonter la pente
remonter la pente mais le pas oublier un
mémorial en hommage aux victimes de
l'attentât a justement été érigés par la
ville de nice sur la promenade des
anglais où s'est déroulé l'attentât le
nom des 86 victimes ya été gravé et on
poursuit cette édition dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du conseil
d'état qui rejette la demande de
réouverture des discothèques le
gouvernement avocat risque trop grand de
dissémination du virus puis nous
parlerons de l'europe à quelques jours
d'un sommet crucial qui devra trancher
sur un plan de relance de 750 milliards
d'euros à rester avec nous sur rt rance
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 usines et les
autos pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel
d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
monde d'avant il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver pensé que
ça allait me rendre plus tolérante et ça
m'a rendu plus intolérant alors par sms
et d'expression vous proposait justement
délirer autour d'un dessert que j'ai
appelé la pêche la patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde d'avant
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
à
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
ap
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
il est 21h30 heure de paris soit y lé
bienvenu merci de nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france alors que le 14
juillet est habituellement un jour de
fête du côté du monde de la nuit le
moral est en berne
il n'y aura pas de réouverture des
discothèques le conseil d'état a rejeté
un recours formulé par le syndicat
national des discothèques et lieux de
loisirs lé club espérait pouvoir ouvrir
leurs portes le 10 juillet elle même
avec un simple service de bar le refus
du conseil d'état provoque la colère des
professionnels de la nuit et on en parle
tout de suite avec elle l'un d'entre eux
mathieu le bras il est porte parole des
gérants des discothèques de normandie 1
mathieu lebrun merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france alors
emmanuel macron n'a pas abordé à votre
cas aujourd'hui votre profession se
sentait l'abandonner
ah bah c'est pas que abandonné c'est
beaucoup de fatigue depuis un mois pour
défendre leur métier de la colère de
l'incompréhension
quand on voit ce qui se passe
actuellement en france c'est à dire
qu'actuellement
emmanuel macron olivier ferrand edouard
philippe pour notre ancien premier
ministre et notre premier ministre
actuel sont en train de créer des
clusters géant dans notre pays parce
qu'il nous et ne nous écoute pas et il
l'espère des choses très très grave
c'est fabienne il ne vous écoute pas à
se dire que vous aviez proposé d vous
aviez fait formuler des propositions
concrètes pour une réouverture possible
eh bien écoutez oui on a proposé un
protocole sanitaire plus qu'ambitieux un
protocole sanitaire qui du jamais vu et
qui est presque à l'encontre de notre
dans notre métier
un protocole sanitaire qui n'existe dans
aucun autre métier actuellement des
confiné et actuellement nous ne sommes
pas écoutés et surtout encore pire c'est
à dire que nous allons nous avons mené
des actions nous les petits patrons
discothèque en dehors de nos syndicats
nous avons rencontré edouard philippe
sur un bout de trottoir avant qu'ils
votent au havre nous avons rencontré v
entre ont contré par dont olivier
ferrand sur un bouton touareg allemande
en a parlé et hier nous avons rencontré
grégory emeric et le responsable
technique à la santé pour le premier
ministre qui nous a complètement avouer
que actuellement
depuis notre engagement ils n'ont même
pas encore lieu notre protocole
sanitaire
c'est à dire qu'en ce moment pendant je
vous parle je vous parle d'un protocole
sanitaire plus que faure est incroyable
alors c'est quoi justement c'est quoi
justement ce protocole sanitaire qu'est
ce que vous proposez concrètement en
cette période de crise pour que les gens
puissent venir danser en boîte de nuit
nous proposons donc on part sur le
protocole sanitaire des bars on a bien
compris qu le conseil scientifique avait
beaucoup de d'inquiétude au niveau de la
piste de danse
on supprime la piste de danse
complètement le port du masque pour tous
les déplacements dans le bar dans là
dans la discothèque parlons sur la piste
de danse on met des tables on va les
écarter évidemment comme ce qui est
prévu dans les restaurants et dans les
bars on demande juste
évidemment que les gens qui sont autour
de la table on puisse les faire danser
par groupe
on va évidemment les la prise de
température le gel hydroalcoolique
on va et surtout ce qui est important ce
qu'il faut bien écouter c'est une
traçabilité nos clients on a une
application stop qu'ovide qui a dû
coûter très cher à notre pays france où
personne ne s'abonne nous allons pas
l'imposer mais fortement conseillée à
nos clients de l'avoir pour rentrer dans
le moule hypothèques et si on quelqu'un
ne veulent pas on fera des fiches sur
nos clients c'est à dire que s'ils ne
veulent pas la voir
on prend un nom prénom adresse numéro de
téléphone et demain est ce qui existe en
suisse parce qu'olivier véran ne dit pas
la vérité dans l'hémicycle en dix ans
les discothèques quand il le prend
l'exemple de la suisse on pourra avoir
une traçabilité ce qui n'existe pas en
ce moment sur les rave parties et les
free parties les fêtes privées qui sont
par milliers en france tous les
week-ends avec mais aucune charge et
justement on voit des images à l'antenne
alors que vous parlez quand vous voyez
ces images de concerts de rassemblement
sans gestes barrières sans masque quel
est votre sentiment justement mais c'est
à dire juste comme je voulais dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que là en ce moment
l'état est en train de créer tout seul
c'est deuxième vague
on nous parle l arrivée les dalles est
ce que l'on aura vraiment lu
je ne souhaite pas d'ailleurs mais
réellement ont fait l'état laisse toutes
les mais tout ce qui est possible pour
qu'elle soit créé on laisse n'importe
qui créent des soirées je parle je pense
à cette rave party qui a lieu où marlène
schiappa dit bah on est impuissant alors
on amène des masques et du gel
ça veut dire qu'en ce moment la fête non
gérer la fête qui normalement ne doit
pas avoir lieu
on le laisse faire et pendant ce temps
là j'ai eu l'exemple d'un patron qui a
tenté d'ouvrir parce que il est pris à
la gorge financièrement 25 ans de sa vie
va partir à la poubelle parce qu'il ne
peut pas ouvrir
on nous demande encore de payer
certaines charges de l'état alors qu'on
ne rendent plus de chiffre d'affaires a
tenté d'ouvrir samedi et dimanche
on l'a mis en garde à vue monsieur en
garde à vue avec le passage au tribunal
au mois de février mais où on est c'est
à dire des gens qui consacrent leur vie
à des patrons d'établissements
actuellement qui ont payé leur dû à
l'état qui paye des charges on est
traité pour comme des moins que rien des
délinquants c'est incroyable on nous
sommes des professionnels de la fête et
on ne nous écoute pas je râle vraiment
on est outré c'est incroyable ce
justement est-ce que selon vous il ya
une défiance envers le monde de la nuit
est ce que finalement vous souffrez pas
d'une mauvaise réputation
eh ben il ya eu des années je suis je
suis heureux soit dispo dès qu'on est
d'accord mais à regarder moi j'ai 40 ans
sa fille de dix ans je suis patron de
discothèque
je gère mon établissement comme
n'importe quelle entreprise les années
sulfureuse des années 80 ou peut-être 90
si vous voulez c'est fini il reste
encore quelques brouilles galeuses comme
dans n'importe quel métier mais c'est
fini tout ça
par contre effectivement si l'état nous
nous laisse nous abandonne nous sommes
des métiers où les banques ne prêtent
pas d'argent
demain si il ya bien deux discothèques
qui dépose le bilan et un jour cette
épidémie sera fini il y aura peut-être
un vaccin
les gens qui auront le cash pour
racheter les discothèques ce sera les
deals ce seront les dealers qui vont
racheter ses discothèques et on
repartira dans ses récits furieuse avec
des gens qui serviront de nos
établissements comme blanchisserie et là
l'état encore une fois on continue dans
la bêtise dans l'année on écoute pas on
ne nous écoute pas on est en train de
prévenir
peut-être une deuxième vague on en train
de prévenir sur la suite de ce qui va se
passer et non la sourde oreille
c'est juste un progression je lance un
appel à emmanuel macron au premier
ministre à olivier véran par pitié
écoutez nous c'est juste incroyable
alors effectivement il ya le volet santé
mais s'ils ne veulent pas nous écouter
au moins trouver une solution avec bercy
avec des moyens financiers comme le
comme l'a fait l'allemagne
effectivement effectivement aujourd'hui
qu'elles sont l'état de vos finances
vous vous avez été obligé de licencier
ah bah non pour l'instant on a le
chômage partiel le chômage partiel doit
large c'est à dire que on protège l'état
évite d'avoir des chômeurs un peu
partout en france en plus à cause de
tout ça donc non je n'ai pas licencier
tout le monde est au chômage partiel
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'on a
des temps plein mais on a beaucoup de
temps partiels qui ne sont pas
remboursés à 100 % actuellement
quand je paye tous les salaires de mes
employés je suis à 2000 j'ai deux mille
euros de ma poche de ma société qui
n'est pas remboursé par l'état et ça
depuis le mois d'avril monsieur donc
effectivement ça devient un peu
compliqué même pour ça je suis à cent
trente mille euros de trésorerie qui
sont partis parlent par les fenêtres
c'est c'est juste tout bonnement
incroyable de pouvoir laisser tout un
pan d'une société pas de une activité
comme ça à disparaître à la poubelle
merci bonsoir
et surtout je finirai excusez moi ce qui
me met en avant juste pour terminer ce
qui me choque le plus
actuellement c'est quand je vois notre
gouvernement quant à nous parler d'une
réforme de retraites ou alors on vient
de dépenser 130 millions d'euros pour le
coc vide pour l'attelage la gestion du
coc vide
comment peut-on avoir un calcul des
retraites en ayant dépensé déjà 130
millions d'euros on parle de avant ou
après tout est incohérent sa mère à
boulot merci
mathieu lebrun on a bien entendu votre
colère et votre souffrance je rappelle
que vous êtes porte parole des gérants
des discothèques de normandie un virus
actifs notamment en espagne où plus de
120 nouveaux foyers de contamination ont
été détectés
conséquence de nombreuses régions
renforcer leurs mesures de restriction
comme en catalogne où le port du masque
est obligatoire
à tout moment dans une partie de la
région il est même question de
reconfirmer la population mais cette
décision fait l'objet d'un bras de fer
juridique explications françois xavier
lambert attablés en terrasse ou
circulant dans les rues masque sur le
visage les habitants de lérida ne semble
pas encore concernés par un possible
reconfirmant de leur ville alors que le
nombre de cas de kovy 19 repart à la
hausse en catalogne
le gouvernement local a décidé d'imposer
de nouvelles restrictions de déplacement
dans cette zone située à 150 km à
l'ouest de barcelone mais le tribunal
supérieur de catalogne a refusé de
valider cette mesure qu'il juge
contraire au droit
une décision de justice qui n'altère pas
la détermination du gouvernement local
et quand on accepte même la région étant
donné que nous n'acceptons pas la
décision judiciaire le gouvernement de
la généralité prend l'initiative dans
les prochaines heures sous la
supervision d'un conseil exécutif
extraordinaire d'approuver un décret
pour établir un plan de résurgence et
pour pouvoir agir avec toute la force
nécessaire dans tous les points du pays
en fonction des chiffres de l'évolution
épidémiologique ce bras de fer
judiciaire se joue sur fond de défiance
persistante entre les autorités
catalanes et le gouvernement central
pour le ministre espagnol de la santé
les nouveaux foyers de contamination ne
nécessite pas de réimposer un
confinement à la population locale
nous sommes en contact direct et
permanent avec les autorités sanitaires
du gouvernement catalan et même s'il
n'ya pas d'autorisation du juge
nous sommes conscients que leurs
services juridiques travail pour voir
comment ils peuvent obtenir
l'autorisation de prendre des mesures
adéquates à la réalité de l'épidémie
leur permettant de contrôler l'épidémie
dans la région de ses grilles à face à
cette bataille judiciaire de nombreux
habitants de lérida se disent inquiets à
lérida il ya des secteurs qui ne sont
pas contrôlés
cela crée une insécurité les gens
commencent à perdre le sommeil parce
qu'ils ont peur la peur nous touche en
ce moment on devra aussi équiper
davantage d'hôpitaux embaucher plus de
professionnels et testé tout le monde
et ensuite dire s'il faut confiné ou pas
maintenant comme il nous confie ça sera
pire parce qu'on va encore tout fermé et
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on relèvera la
tête
la catalogne n'est pas la seule région
espagnole à être concernée par de
nouveaux foyers de contagion
plus de 120 autres sont actifs
actuellement dans le pays pour faire
face la plupart des régions impose le
port du masque à tout moment dans la rue
comme dans les espaces publics fermés
la pandémie de coronavirus ça fait à ce
jour plus de 28000 400 morts en espagne
et on en vient à cette semaine
européenne décisif pour emmanuel macron
dès demain le chef de l'état recevra les
dirigeants espagnols et suédois
à trois jours d'un sommet qui s'annonce
cruciale concernant le plan de relance
européen est les précisions avec florian
lambert après le jour de fête nationale
place désormais à l'europe dans l'agenda
des manuels macron en vue du sommet qui
aura lieu les 17 18 juillet prochain le
président de la république accueillera
ce mercredi à l'elysée pedro sanchez
le chef du gouvernement espagnol puis le
lendemain le premier ministre suédois
stefan lowen dès jeudi soir le chef de
l'état se rendra à bruxelles la veille
de cette réunion décisive qui devrait
trancher sur le plan de relance
économique un fonds de 750 milliards
d'euros qui peine à convaincre les
quatre frugaux l'autriche les pays bas
la suède et la finlande qui dénoncent un
projet favorable aux pays du sud
lundi la chancelière allemande angela
merkel a fait part de ses doutes sur la
possibilité pour les dirigeants des
vingt-sept de parvenir à un accord cette
semaine
nous discuterons vendredi de la manière
dont nous pouvons parvenir à un accord
commun nos positions sont différentes je
ne peux pas dire si nous parviendrons à
un accord vendredi
mais ce serait en tout cas bien pour
l'europe la hongrie de viktor orban
devrait elle aussi s'opposer au plan de
relance à bruxelles
emmanuel macron devra donc se montrer
particulièrement convaincant pour éviter
un nouveau couac au sein de l'union
européenne
ces échanges traduisent la mobilisation
totale du président de la république
pour obtenir dès ce mois de juillet un
accord sur le budget de l'union
européenne et un plan de relance
européen très ambitieux indispensable à
la reprise économique dans l'union et la
zone euro un sommet qui s'annonce donc
décisif pour l'avenir de l'organisation
les conséquences de la pandémie due
coronavirus provoqueront selon bruxelles
une baisse de 8,7 pour cent du pib de la
zone euro en 2020 et en italie est la
colère contre la gestion de la crise
sanitaire ne retombe pas hier une
centaine de personnes ont manifesté
devant le tribunal de bergame cette
ville la plus touchée par la pandémie à
payer le tribut le plus lourd avec 3100
morts et près de 14000 4 contamination
familles et proches des victimes
réclament justice le point avec leïla
serraf à bergame le rassemblement
organisé par le comité vérité et justice
pour les victimes de kovy de 19
leurs avocats ont adressé une lettre à
la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen et au
président de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
robert ragnar ce panneau l'objectif les
invite à superviser les enquêtes en
cours en lombardie
aujourd'hui au bureau du procureur de
bergame
nous déposons s'en plaint après notre
premier jour de mobilisation le 10 juin
dernier
nous voulons simplement savoir
exactement ce qui s'est passé ici et le
virus est partout dans le monde mais
surtout pourquoi à bergame brechtien et
la lombardie il a fait un massacre
énorme nous voulons voir s'il ya un
responsable ou s'il s'agit simplement de
la fatalité
les familles des victimes en colère
aujourd'hui il n'est plus question de se
taire certaines d'entre elles n'hésitent
plus à mettre en cause directement les
autorités locales et l'exécutif italien
je pense qu'ils ont tout raté que ce
soit la région où le gouvernement
ils n'ont pas réussi à gérer la
situation il était dépassé
selon les données officielles la
lombardie a enregistré plus de 16 mille
décès soit presque la moitié du nombre
total de victimes de kovy de 19 en
italie et on revient tout de suite sur
ce sommet européen à une semaine
décisive pour emmanuel macron dès demain
le chef de l'état recevra les dirigeants
espagnols et suédois à trois jours donc
de ce sommet qui s'annonce crucial on va
tout de suite en parlait avec françois
poulet mathis il est journaliste
spécialiste de l'europe
françois poulet mathis merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on le
disait à l'instant emmanuel macron va
recevoir les dirigeants espagnols et
suédois il échangera il échangera de
nouveau avec angela merkel et puis avec
guise ep comté est ce que finalement
tout se joue maintenant avant le sommet
oui vous savez dans toute négociation
les positions générales ce cap
durcissement près de la solution
pensez bien ce qui se passe sur une
planète qu'elle affirme et ses joutes
chic elle avait des doutes sur la
possibilité d'un accord ' en trois ans
c'est aussi parce que fondamentalement
elle souhaite pousser les gens jusqu'à
leurs limites et les inciter de tête
c'est d'accepter des concessions pour
rien la corvée de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit quand même d'un budget
européen pluriannuel qui est important
de milliards d'euros c'est quelque chose
de considérable et en plus ce pied le
résultat d'un accord avec entre anglet
la merkel emmanuel macron 750 milliards
d'euros qui vont être injectés dans
l'économie européenne pour la relance et
lui prennent c'est que ces 750 milliards
d'euros qui vont être de deux roues qui
l'ont être lucide il y est en fait la
commission rappelle qu'il a acheté de la
dette chaud et marché et bien cette
quête va être mutualisés or elle a
profité essentiellement aux pays qui ont
le plus souffert du combat virus est
banni
spy et bien sûr la france or d'autres
pays
ce que ce qu'on appelle précisément les
pays qui sont précoces chez eux s'ils
n'ont pas envie de voir le budget
sécurité telles que les quatre pays en
question
le danemark la suède les pays bas et
l'autriche est bien fait 4 b ils disent
qu il faut des garanties avant de
traiter la alors clairement justement
justement françois poulet mathis selon
vous qu'est ce qui pourrait faire
changer d'avis les pays dits frugaux que
vous venez de citer dans les pays
flocons peuvent changer dans la vie
d'avis dans la mesure où ils ont
l'impression que l'octroi de prêts et
surtout de la subvention disent que les
subventions finalement c'est de la
fraude c'est de l'argent qui n'est pas
soumis à remboursement à condition que
ces conditions qui a contre la véritable
contrôle de l'ensemble des 27 pays de
l'union sur l'utilisation de ces fonds
et surtout un engagement de ces pays à
accompagner
finalement si je suis bon questions de
réformes profondes réformes de l'art
économique donc il mêle ses gars entier
il ya eu beaucoup de pourparlers ses
dalons tas il va y en avoir encore
demain et peut-être dans la soirée ces
pourparlers ont pour objet finalement de
faire accepter à ses pays l'ine qui
serait quand même un petit saut
révolutionnaire en europe
la difficulté est le drame du canda
virus qui a touché pas l'europe de
manière égale et bien que chez quand un
virus plus atteindra sur lequel
l'ensemble des pays européens puissent
30 revanche en injectant dans les codes
de vie et on veut tuer les gens leur s
affrontent c'est un jeu suite à des
freins ou claira et chuta renouveau sion
de l'europe si si effectivement un
accord est trouvé ce qui n'est pas
encore le cas
alors justement est ce que c'est le plan
de la dernière chance pour l'europe ou
alors est-ce qu'on se dirige vers le une
europe divisée entre les pays du nord et
les pays du sud
c'est à grand risque c'est un grand
risque mais tout le monde mesure le
riche quand l'allemagne d'angela merkel
a réalisé que finalement elle était
obligée d'accepter l'idée de
mutualisation des efforts je pense
qu'elles apprennent bien compris une
menace qui concerne la nature même du
marché intérieur
toute l'économie européenne une telle
menace sera redoutable
y compris pour tous les pays pris
séparément et donc même les petits pays
qui actuellement est à
peut-être et ce n'est pas impossible que
finalement ils en viennent à une
certaine forme de raisons pour peu qu'on
leur donne des gages et ses gages c'est
quoi c'est la possibilité effectivement
d'avoir leur mot à dire sur la manière
dont l'argent qui va les énormités de
l'argent qui décidera
l'utilisation de cet argent soit soumis
à un contrôle rigoureux là un plan 127
par le biais de la commission européenne
et par le plus du concert église
merci beaucoup françois poulet mathis
devoir partager votre expertise sur
leurs antennes rappelle que vous êtes
journalistes et spécialistes europe et
c'est la fin de cette édition vous
restez avec nous sur rt france dans
quelques minutes on fait un nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité a tout de
suite
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
co fondatrice